m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cierren los ojos por cinco segundos por
favor
imagínense
que mickey mouse se quedó hoy sin
trabajo
ya los pueden abrir
se los cuento por qué
hace dos semanas tuve un sueño o mejor
una pesadilla
en ese sueño veía una noticia grande en
un diario internacional que decía que se
acababa disney no más disney
que a partir de la fecha se cerraban los
parques en orlando
que se ha acabado en las películas que
se recogían todos los peluches que
estaban
en las diferentes casas y apartamentos
que ya no se iba a producir más
programas de televisión
que mickey mouse' quedaba sin trabajo y
que la cenicienta
despedía
todo esto pasaba porque hace dos meses
exactamente acompañaba a un amigo a un
tribunal en bogotá donde un juez dictó
la siguiente sentencia
no la el despido de mickey no no fue
un embargo secuestro de bienes no
lo que pasó ahí con mi amigo fue que le
ordenaron dejar de usar su marca la que
había construido durante cinco años y
que en el año 2
por diferencias con su socio que se
retira del proyecto by la registra sin
avisarle a él ni a su equipo de trabajo
dos años más adelante le llegue a una
carta
una carta fría y una carta triste
señor
elías a partir de la fecha está
prohibida el uso de la marca x
para el evento x
por orden judicial
el en esa preocupación me llama y me
dice juan carlos que hacemos la marca la
creé yo hace 5 años pero existe un
título que dice lo contrario
después de buscar y buscar y horas de
pasar de ser el abogado al psicólogo
porque lloraba y lloraba este artista
buscamos una solución
dentro de lo que se podría rescatar y
que fue negociar la marca
mi amigo elías terminó pagando 40 mil
dólares por que le regresaran su idea
porque le regresaran su marca
por eso cuando tuve la pesadilla de
disney que se iba acabar me acordé de mi
amigo pero en el caso de disney que se
acabó
que acaba con disney las películas
se seguirán produciendo películas
los peluches
no
que se acaba con disney se acaba el
legado más importante
de creatividad innovación y sentimientos
que he conocido en mi vida
por eso
las marcas son tan importantes para los
emprendedores y en este día a día de mi
trabajo logré entender que lo importante
no es registrar
no
eso es lo menos importante de registrar
lo más importante me ha dado la
experiencia es
valorar por eso sabiamente mi papá
a quien amo tanto
me decía en la juventud cuando yo estaba
en el colegio y empezaba a tener mis
amoríos
me decía tranquilo mi hijo ella algún
día van a entender
que nadie sabe lo que tiene hasta que lo
pierde cierto y pues esas frases fueron
modificando mi pensamiento de ser
periodista
tuve el gran privilegio de trabajar con
andrea guerrero pero en mí existía otra
cosa
de esa frase de nadie sabe lo que tiene
hasta que lo pierde empecé a amar el
derecho me volvió abogado en la
universidad
después empecé a estudiar
sobre algo apasionante la propiedad
intelectual
cuando escuché esa frase de mi papá
tomé una decisión muy importante para mi
vida algo que llevo en las venas
a lo que me dedico actualmente proteger
marcas porque nadie sabe lo que tiene
hasta que se lo registra
sí
entonces en ese día a día constante
sentándome con emprendedores sentándome
con empresarios
uno va escuchando historias de que me
robaron la marca no sé si esto pasa acá
me robaron la idea me robaron el
proyecto pero pocos se interesan por
conocer algo que se llama el sistema
internacional de propiedad intelectual
pero antes de conocer el sistema
ustedes se han preguntado alguna vez
cuánto vale una marca
cuanto vale su marca
porque en la historia de disney cuando
dan la orden de no usar más la marca
disney se rompe ese matrimonio entre
marca y seguidor y ya que hablamos de
matrimonios porque uno elige a la pareja
que tiene si mira en allí al de al lado
y pregúntele a usted por qué lo
eligieron de novio sí porque lo
eligieron de esposo
si uno a veces es desordenado se le
olvidan las fechas especiales
en mi caso duró horas y horas sentado
frente al computador viendo charlas ted
tanto que la visualización y su estar
acá
pero lo terminan eligiendo uno eligen
este gatito
que quiere ser un tigre o que quiere ser
un león
entonces
qué es lo importante saber qué valor
tenemos qué valor tiene nuestra marca
porque al final del día no se están
eligiendo pero sabe una cosa 19 line lo
mejor
estoy totalmente convencido de eso uno
elige lo que le gusta
y así pasa con las marcas todo el tiempo
estamos eligiendo entre a / b y ahora en
13 y las marcas tienen una función
fundamental ahorrarle el cerebro cuando
empieza a elegir le ahorra tiempo cuando
empieza a elegir entre a b o c
pero gracias a dios conocí
el sistema de propiedad intelectual la
organización mundial de la propiedad
intelectual está ubicada en suiza
y en su más reciente estudio dice que en
el 2016
existían 36.5 millones de marcas activas
esto en otras palabras quiere decir que
si nos equiparamos con canadá
cada ciudadano canadiense tendría un
título marcar
pero si lo más importante del
emprendedor es su marca porque no la
valoramos porque no la protegemos
hay una gran deficiencia no solamente en
el sistema gubernamental porque hoy todo
el mundo habla de economía naranja de
innovación pero pocos hablamos de cómo
vamos a proteger nuestras ideas cómo
vamos a hacer que ese inventor que es
emprendedor que ese creativo pueda
proteger y crecer porque si usamos bien
el sistema
podremos tener beneficios como
exclusividad distinción
pero mejor aún podríamos tener
oportunidades de expansión
expansión con diferentes modalidades
como las franquicias cómo llevar
nuestros productos o servicios a otros
mercados
pero volviendo a la historia de mi amigo
de elías
siempre que hablamos me dice
el remedio salió
peor que la enfermedad
sí
esto es de todos los días tuve el
privilegio de trabajar en la
superintendencia industria y comercio y
veía como rostros
confundidos tristes no podían lograr el
registro de sus marcas
pero para mí existen tres elementos
fundamentales para poder saber si mi
marca puede llegar a ser protegida
el primero
verificar
de datos o en donde quieran en internet
si la marca que estoy usando un tercero
lactando igual o similar a la mía
segundo definir muy bien qué clase de
producto o servicio voy a ofrecer al
mercado y la tercera más importante nos
entra en los libros pero a dios gracias
la experiencia no le ha dado
tener una visión global de las marcas
porque una visión global de las marcas
porque a veces nos quedamos
con él
ese poquito más allá y nos damos la
mitad extra
para llevar nuestras marcas a otro nivel
imagínense su pesca en otro idioma en
otro acento en otro país más allá del
letrero que está frente
a su negocio
por un momento imagínense que su marca
es mickey mouse
y hoy niños en español en inglés
en mandarín y hasta mi hijo que tiene 7
meses
se divierte con este ratoncito creado
por walter elias disney
así que
el llamado es para que sigamos innovando
sigamos generando ideas de valor
ideas que logren cambiar el mundo y
transformar las realidades de la
sociedad pero protejamos esas ideas
cuidemos las cómo cuidamos cosas
materiales a veces nos preocupamos más
por nuestro celular que por lo que
producimos acá a veces nos preocupamos
más si el vehículo en el que vamos es
bonito o no es bonito pero no nos
preocupamos por lo que realmente tiene
valor que son los intangibles como lo
llaman los abogados pero para mí los
sueños porque cada vez que atendemos un
emprendedor en nuestra empresa atendemos
un sueño y lo acompañamos para que ese
sueño se haga realidad es haber
oportunidades donde antes él no veía así
que para qué
la pesadilla que tuve hace unos meses
hace unas semanas
no vaya a ser un sueño sólo mío sino que
vaya a ser de pronto una realidad de
algunos de ustedes
vamos a registrar a partir de hoy todas
nuestras creaciones así que muchachos en
sus marcas listos registren muchas
gracias
[Música]